neil theo
congratulations you've made it into the
finale for this competition
there's only one thing you have left to
do and that is to go back home
and recreate an iconic weapon from
history
the tai chi sword
emerging from china over 2 500 years ago
the tai chi sword is known as the
gentleman of weapons due to its
refinement and sophistication
symbolizing power and authority the
weapon is one of the most common ancient
weapons still in practice
with millions of students studying it
worldwide fast and light its straight
double-edged blade was used for quick
stabs and lethal cuts
while the sword's fairly blunt lower
section was built to block and deflect
attacks its reputation is also preserved
in popular culture through its role as
the coveted green destiny sword in the
film crouching tiger hidden dragon
your blade must be double edged have a
winged guard
and pommel last time i was on the show i
made a naginata
in comparison the tai chi sword has a
lot more blade
it's gonna be a lot of work
you will have five days at your home
force to accomplish this at the end of
five days you'll return and present your
work to our panel of expert judges
and only after they've brutally tested
them will they declare one of you
the forged and fire champion of
champions and give you that cash
i'm concerned because the tai chi sword
it's really light
i probably have regular knives that are
heavier than that
pole sword so that's a challenge for me
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days best of luck man
my name is neil kamimura i was asked to
come back and i would never say no to my
fortune fire family
what i feel i've come back for is to
represent the people
just starting off and show them that you
can do this
i gotta build a tai chi sword this is
the first time i've ever
made something this long but
i'm never gonna quit
the blade has to be heated evenly trying
to get the sword
lighter it's been kind of difficult and
being that this is the longest thing
i've ever heat treated
i'm not really set up for it
i can feel it want to bend because of
the weight of the tip
so i am scared if something goes wrong
i won't have time to fix it
my blade is straight i don't have to
re-quench it
i'm stoked my name is theo nas
winning fortune fire allowed me to turn
my hobby into a full-time career in
knife making and teaching
the biggest obstacle is the raw amount
of forging i have to do then getting the
guard to forge weld to the blade itself
and then being able to forge the pomelon
as well
if the welds don't hold everything will
be coming apart
how important are guards on swords they
can be integral
put on the quench
big moment of truth if things go wrong
right now
i gotta start again so no pressure
perfectly straight things went amazingly
well
i'm happy with the blade if i win the
money would most likely go to starting a
new life with my wife
i had to put that in there i get in
trouble for him
oh god we're still recording i'm sorry
daisy
[Music]
theo neil welcome back to the forge
theo tell us about your blade went very
well
i did an integral garden pummel by forge
welding on both of them
the blades handled is relatively simple
construction so that it can be
beaten if you sound monotony excited
about that neil how'd it go for you man
same recipe as the last time i was here
go to the junkyard
get some stuff because i didn't expect
to make it this far
all right well gentlemen up first is the
strength test
ben champions i'm going to be hitting
this bamboo
five times remember it's not what your
sword does to the bamboo but what the
bamboo does to your sword
theo you're up first how you feeling a
little nervous
let's go for it
[Music]
[Music]
well theo this is a root of a sword the
edge held up perfectly i don't see any
problems
still straight as an arrow the handle is
a little bit difficult to really control
i would have liked a little bit more
meat on it but very well done
thank you neil you're up next boy
that's a tough test that bamboo
setup is literally just blunt force
trauma
i don't think a lot of blades can
survive that kind of
jarring and punishment
[Music]
oh neil sword is heavy i wouldn't want
to be
running around with it there's a little
bit of damage that the bamboo gave back
to your sword
but it's still straight alrighty well
done nice job
thank you next up is the sharpness test
for that dave
all right gentlemen i'm going to be
chopping through these tatami mats using
both edges of your sword let's see if
your blades still have an edge
yo you're up first you ready for that
yeah yeah
sure i'm very nervous at this point
this is the make it or break it moment i
have to perform well on this test
[Music]
[Music]
all right theo definitely a sharp blade
you can see the
nice clean slice and then burying into
the second i like the design
it's definitely a solid piece that's one
of the nice things about it
i don't feel like it's gonna go anywhere
hold on
thank you all right neal you ready
[Music]
yep
so the biggest thing is all that weight
about twice what it needs to be as far
as weight goes
it's difficult to swing and then the
edge of this blade
it's got a very stout profile almost
like an axe
just kept it from cutting all the way
through
theo neil we took five champions we
whittled it down to two
but there can only be one forged and
fire champion of champions
that champion is
theo congratulations neil unfortunately
your weapon did not make the cut
neil you came up and shows that you had
the heart to make it to the finals
and against four other champions but
your sword took some damage to the
strength test
but more than that it's heavy a tai chi
sword is known to be strong
sharp and light for those reasons we
have to let you go
neal please surrender your weapon
i 100 agree with the judges theo earned
it
but i don't look at this as a failure in
any means
because i gave it my all i can walk away
look everybody in the eye and have
everyone's respect
and that's worth more to me than any
title
or any amount of money
theo congratulations you are the new
fortune fire champion of champions and
will be receiving a check for ten
thousand dollars
how you feel right now oh that's why the
butterflies and the nerves are still
going but thank you guys
please present your weapon to the judges
[Laughter]
my ego was pretty big beforehand and uh
i think this is only going to inflate it
[Music]
not a good thing not a bad thing
i think
you